معنا من خان يونس الصحفي اسماعيل ابو عمر
اسماعيل سلسله غارات اذا تستهدف منطقه خان
يونس ما هي اخر
التحديثات نعم في خانيونس غارتان متزامنان
قبل قليل في وسط المحافظه وكذلك الى اقصى
الجنوب من محافظه خانيونس والان ايضا يسمع
ذوي انفجارات جديده في الاجزاء الشرقيه
ووسط محافظه خانيونس الان السنه الدخان
تتصاعد كما نشاهد في الصوره نتيجه هذه
الغارات التي نفذها طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في منطقه خانيونس هناك
مناشدات خاصه في القصف الذي وقع في جنوب
خان يونس مناشدات من بعض المواطنين بضروره
توجيه سيارات اسعاف الى تلك المنطقه على
ما يبدو ان هناك اصابات نتيجه هذا القصف
ولا نعلم ان كان القصف قد استهدف منزلا او
اي هدف اخر استهدفته طائرات الاحتلال في
ذلك المكان بالقرب من صاله كندا تحديدا
الى الجنوب من محافظه خانيونس وقبل قليل
ايضا كان استهداف اخر بالتزامن مع هذا
القصف في وسط المحافظه كما نشاهد في هذه
اللحظات السنه الدخان تتصاعد حتى هذه
اللحظه سحابه بيضاء وسحابه سوداء وسحب
كثيره في اجزاء مختلفه من المحافظه تصاعد
في هذه اللحظات نتيجه غارات الاحتلال
اضافه الى القصف المدفع الذي لا يتوقف بين
الحين والاخر من قبل اليات الاحتلال
المتمركزه داخل مناطق في وسط محافظه
خانيونس وكذلك في المناطق الشرقيه
للمحافظه هناك في يعني في هذه المناطق
التي تشهد او تكون مسرحا لعمليات الاحتلال
القصف لم يتوقف منذ الليله الماضيه هذه
اللحظه خاصه القصف المدفعي ويحدث اصوات
انفجارات ضخمه في مناطق مختلفه يسمع دوي
هذه الانفجارات وايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه
لقطاع غزه تحديدا في مدينه رفح كان هناك
استهدافات من قبل اليات الاحتلال وقصف
مدفعي عنيف بالقرب من شارع العوده المحاذي
للشريط الفاصل في شرق مدينه
رفح المعلومات كانت تتوارد بان هناك عمليه
توغل في تلك المنطقه الى الشرق من مدينه
رفح لكن هذه المعلومات تبين انها غير
دقيقه وما حدث وعمليات قصف مدفعيه قامت
بها اليات الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه
الانفجارات لا تتوقف في جنوب قطاع غزه
خاصه في مدينه خانيونس حتى هذه اللحظه
اليات الاحتلال لا تزال تقوم باعمال
حفريات في المناطق التي توغلت فيها منذ
اليوم اليوم او العدوان البري على محافظه
خار يونس وتقوم ايضا مع هذه الحفريات
باطلاق النار بشكل كثيف من قبل اليات
الاحتلال احيانا تشارك طائرات المروحيه
الاسرائيليه في عمليات اطلاق النار اضافه
الى الغطاء الناري من قبل طائرات الاحتلال
الحربيه والتي تنفذ غارات باتجاه اهداف
عديده وكثيره في محافظه خان يونس عديد
الغارات التي نفذت التي لم نستطع تحديدها
خاصه في المناطق الشرقيه نظرا ل
لنضم المصادر في تلك المناطق وتلك المناطق
لا يستطيع احد الوصول اليها في ظل الحصار
المفروض عليها منذ اليوم الاول الذي قامت
به بعمليه قامت بها قوات الاحتلال
بعملياتها البريه في محافظه خانيونس لا
يستطيع احد الوصول المناطق هناك حديث من
قبل المواطنين الذين يستطيعون احيانا
الوصول الى تلك المناطق عبر طرق الفافيه
بان هناك عديد من الشهداء في ملقون على
الاراضي في او في الشوارع في المناطق
الشرقيه لمحافظه فونس ينجح البعض بانتشال
هؤلاء بعض الشهداء عر عبر العربات التيجر
حيوانات ولكن هناك عدد كبير اخر مازال
ملقى على الارض حتى هذه اللحظه ومر على
استشهادهم ايام وبعضهم مر على استشهادهم
اسابيع عموما الموقف هنا في
محافظه على ما يبدو ان متجه ال الى مزيد
من التص في ظل استمرار القص الص المدفعي
وكذلك الغارات الاسرائيليه المفه والعنيفه
التي تنفذها طائرات الاحلال الاخر في في
المحافظه وحتى هذه الل يعني برغم هذه
الغارات نستطيع بان يعني يتم استهداف فيها
المناطق التي هي في مصرح عمليه جيش
الاحتلال وحتى اللحظه مع كثره وكثافه هذه
الغارات لم تصل اصابات الى مستشفى ناص
مستشفيات قطاع او جنوب قطاع غزه تحديدا في
مستشفى غزه وكذلك مستشفى ناصر لان المناطق
تلك بيوت البيوت مخلاه لكن لا يعني ذلك
انلا تماما من قبل المواطنين قد يكون هناك
بعض المواطنين مازالوا داخل منازلهم وهذا
الامر يصعب على طواقم الاسعاف الوصول الى
تلك المناطق بسبب القصف العنيف سواء
المدفعي او حتى القصف من قبل طاره
الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا لك من خانيونس الصحفي
اسماعيل ابو عمر